[Music]
it's nearly Halloween and we just can't
get enough spooky and creepy in our
lives we found some terrifying
re-imaginings of Disney Princesses as
evil from artists jeffrey thomas stay
tuned to see the scary dark side of your
favorite princesses
hey Disney fans if you love anything and
everything to do with Disney be sure to
subscribe now let's check out these
chilling drawings of dark Disney
Princesses Snow White cartoon artist and
character designer Jeffrey Thomas took
Disney to a whole new terrifying level
with his creepy series take a look at
Snow White and her Seven Dwarves
you remember Snow White the original
Disney Princess she's the fairest of the
land and is so sweet that forest animals
help her clean
she's dainty in her blue and yellow
dress and she just looks like she could
never do anything evil right wrong this
Snow White is anything but kind her
ivory skin is a chilling white and those
eyes they're just black pits of doom
scary she seems to have enslaved the
Seven Dwarves who all looked kind of
rabid we bet this Snow White would never
let herself get poisoned by the Evil
Queen Ariel The Little Mermaid
definitely romanticized mermaids in most
folklore mermaids are not happy
princesses who want to be human instead
they lure sailors into their dooms in a
watery grave but when we think of
mermaids we think of naive sweet Ariel
she's the lovely daughter of King Triton
in order to become human and meet Prince
Erik she visits the sea witch Ursula
Ursula gives Ariel eggs in exchange for
her voice
[Music]
but in Jeffrey Thomas's artistic version
Arial is the real monster
she's got glowing yellow eyes and a
vicious smile she honestly looks a
little like a zombie with that skin and
Ariel's beloved dingo hopper has
replaced one of her arms she and creepy
flounder look much more like the
monsters that sailors of the past would
talk about she is creepy AF Jasmine
Aladdin's love interest jasmine is one
of the most underrated Disney Princesses
ever you have to be pretty fierce to
have a pet tiger right
the original jasmine is a beautiful
princess who is Basile by things like
magic carpet rides but this version of
Jasmine looks like she's been hanging
out with Jafar a little too long
actually she looks like she could
totally beat Jafar her normally gorgeous
blue outfit has been frayed she's
covered in scars from her tiger but that
just makes her seem even tougher she's
got a sorceress vibe going on and Raja
is not exactly a house pet anymore we
are digging those creepy skull earrings
though something tells us
Aladdin might have to run the opposite
direction if he met this Jasmine Belle
it's no wonder that her name means
beauty according to the villagers in
Beauty and the Beast the Belle we know
and love is lovely and brilliant and a
total bookworm she changes the heart of
the Beast and lives happily ever after
we're a little confused about who the
real Beast is in this drawing though
dark Belle is in her yellow ball gown
but it's frayed she's got hell skin and
evil eyes she looks less than alive and
honestly I were a little terrified the
Beast is behind her with the noose
around his neck did dark Belle seek
revenge on her captor instead of falling
in love with him that is not the tinder
beast we know from the movie this is not
a princess we would want to mess with
that's for sure Pocahontas Disney's
Pocahontas is a classic although it
didn't exactly get the history right
John Smith and his men weren't exactly
nice guys who just left the tribes they
encountered live but in the Disney
version Pocahontas and Don Smith
fall in love and stop their people from
going to war
with the wisdom beyond she teaches John
all about the beauty of nature and house
of paints with all the colors of the
wind
not this Pocahontas Jeffrey Thomas's
version looks like she is ready for war
and we would not want to meet her on the
battlefield she is covered in blood and
wears the skulls of her enemies Miko
looks like he missed his annual rabies
shot and we loved the detail of a
terrifying grandmother' willow in the
background this dark Pocahontas is ready
to protect her people and their home at
any cost it's creepy but it's also full
of girl power
Cinderella the Cinderella we all grew up
with was a beautiful girl forced to live
with her wicked stepmother and
stepsisters they forced her to wait on
them like a servant but she dreamed of a
better life
thanks to her fairy godmother she went
to the ball and fell in love with the
prince
but this cinderella looks like something
straight out of a horror movie
she is dressed in her ball gown but it
looks like the pumpkin isn't the only
thing that changed at midnight
Cinderella is some sort of scarecrow
made of nightmares she looks a little
like she's ready to eat the evil mouse
in her hands the pumpkin goo that is
dripping all over is his disgusting
touch at least it isn't blood we have a
feeling this cinderella may make an
appearance in our dreams tonight and not
in a good way Aurora we all know the
story of Sleeping Beauty a baby princess
is born and she is cursed by the evil
Maleficent in an attempt to save her
from falling into a cursed sleep she is
raised in the woods by three fairies
Aurora falls in love with the prince but
she pricks her finger at the castle and
falls into a long sleep she is awoken by
true love's kiss and they all live
happily ever after
well this Aurora has taken a totally
different turn we can see the blood
dripping from her pricked finger there's
a terrifying owl holding up her hand and
take a look at her face her eyes are
stitched shut that is so creepy the
black lips are an extra spooky touch was
this Aurora raised by Maleficent or
something blue fairy okay we know this
next one isn't a princess but she is
still featured in Jeffrey Thomas's
creepy series and she is extra creepy so
she definitely deserves in
do you remember the Blue Fairy from
Pinocchio she is the one who brings
Pinocchio to life and she is also the
one who turns him into a real boy yes
I've given you life well in this version
she's more of an evil necromancer than a
good fairy
she has turns Pinocchio into a monster
he's eating a heart we hope that is in
Geppetto's hearts and take a look at the
bottom right corner Jiminy Cricket has
been smashed that's so sad if the other
creepy puppets in the background make
this picture extra scary blue fairy's
vicious grin gives us goose bumps
vanellope von schweetz with Ralph breaks
the internet releasing soon everyone has
vanellope on their minds in wreck-it
Ralph
vanellope von schweetz is the missing
princess from the video game sugar rush
due to a glitch she doesn't know she's
the princess all she wants is to become
a real racer in the game she's sassy but
she's also just a good princess Jeffrey
Thomas turned vanellope and sugar rush
into something a lot darker we bet this
videogame
isn't rated E for Everyone Penelope is
armed and dangerous she's writing in a
really creepy vehicle and sugar rush
does not look like a kingdom we want to
visit this isn't your mother's Candy
Land
we would not want to cross this version
of vanilla pee Alice okay we know Alice
isn't technically a princess but she is
a classic Disney character and Jeffrey
Thomas turned her into a nightmare in
the original movie naive ditzy Alice
falls down a rabbit hole and ends up in
the magical world of Wonderland she
meets crazy characters like the Mad
Hatter and the shark at but forget
Wonderland in this version Alice looks
like she's visited the underworld she
has the creepiest grin on her face
there's blood everywhere and it's
dripping from her Mac too we can see the
Mad Hatter's hat but there is no sign of
him this Alice might have had something
to do with that the Cheshire Cat has
always been creepy but he just looks
like pure evil in this drawing this
would make one amazing horror movie
don't you think
Esmeralda The Hunchback of Notre 'adam
is arguably Disney's darkest film it has
some serious political overtones and
messages about discrimination
mistreat this poor boy the same way you
mistreat my people but it's not a horror
film
Esmeralda is the rebellious Romani woman
who seeks refuge in no tree Dom she
befriends Quasimodo she is a strong
woman who speaks out against injustice
but what if she was in a scary movie
Jeffrey Thomas drew Esmeralda as
seriously deformed half her face is
missing her dress is tattered and
covered in what appears to be old blood
the ropes from the cathedral bells are
wrapped around her and what is up with
that goat behind her
he looks all sorts of evil we could
totally get behind the scariest Morel
des seeking revenge Merida the Scottish
princess definitely gets involved with
some dark magic and brave but with the
help of her mother Merida defeats the
evil bear we love Merida because she is
so different from every other princess
she's the only princess to have no
romantic storyline she is also an
amazing Archer and she is true to
herself
in this dark version Jeffrey Thomas
draws her as something even more fierce
she has an evil glare on her face we
suspect she may be on the same side as
the evil bear behind her you can see her
three brothers turn to bear cubs but
they have glowing red eyes they are not
the funny triplets we remember from the
movie there is also a tomb that belongs
to Merida's father King Fergus oh no was
evil Merida responsible for that Tiana
we absolutely adored the story of The
Princess and the Frog
Tiana is a hard-working waitress who
gets turned into a frog along with
Prince Naveen they have to fight an evil
voodoo practitioner to turn back into
humans
Tiana makes a super cute frog in the
movie but not in this version anything
involving voodoo is typically pretty
dark so this illustration makes perfect
sense Tiana is in the swamp and she is a
terrifying frog human hybrid seriously
that tongue is creeping us out she's
wearing dr. facile ears top hat and has
a shrunken skull on her belt the not
quite a live alligator appears to be
eating the voodoo master there are tarot
cards flying and one says revenge
it looks like Tiana gave fasoli or a
taste of his own dark magic this is one
scary reimagining of The Princess and
the Frog Rapunzel
the Rapunzel we know from tangled is an
awesome character she's a little naive
after being locked in a tower her whole
life but she can also defend herself
after Flynn Rider breaks into her castle
she hits him with a frying pan and ties
him up but then she gets him to help her
escape to see the floating lanterns it's
not normal to cut a deal with the thief
who breaks into your home fine I'll take
you to see the lanterns so what would
happen if Rapunzel took defending
herself to the next step we think it
would look something like this
a scared tattered Rapunzel stands in her
tower Flynn's wanted posters are all
over the ground and it appears that
Flynn has met his end and Rapunzel's
hair did you notice how far apart his
arms are that had to be one gruesome
attack yeah we don't think we'll mess
with this Rapunzel
after all being locked in a tower
totally isolated from everyone can
really mess up a person's mind Mulan
let's get down to business with our last
dark Disney Princess Mulan is the
original fierce princess she's disguised
herself as a man so she could take her
father's place in the war then she saved
all of China from the Huns she is a
total hero but Geoffrey Thomas took a
whole new spin on Mulan he turned her
into some scary undead warrior and it's
so cool miss Mulan has taken several
arrows but it doesn't stop her she is
still fighting and where are her eyes
that is so creepy rather than a friendly
time dragon who thinks he's a comedian
Mu Shu is a giant terrifying monster if
we were the Huns and saw this Mulan we
would just run away
which of these creepy Disney characters
was your favorite let us know in the
comments that's it for the dark side of
Disney Princesses if you want more
awesome content click Subscribe and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up
[Music]